So
Chat hier
noch keiner da
Verständlicherweise weil ich habe vor einer sekunde auf stream online gedrückt
Aber kann ja sein wir haben ja ab und zu ja schon die richtig hardcore sub box camper zumindest wird man das auf youtube so nennen
Mal gucken wer der erste heute ist angeblich sind schon die sieben leute da guck mal gucken wer ist der erste
Schmoll exist point am start mein freude allah am start
Gottes abbild der rag man
Exzellent hallo leute ich kann auch ich kann euch sogar hier winken
Nee wir flashen heute gar keine custom firmwärter stimmt nicht
Motke motkes war noch nicht da und haben das noch nicht gefixt und ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht wie ich selber fix
Ich bin dazu lauer q mittlerweile für philip fehlen einfach die prime subs der IQ reicht nicht aus und meine eigene chat statusnachricht zu fixen
Aber ich kann euch schon mal grob sagen was wir heute machen und zwar ich habe hier mein ganz vorbei
Nicht alles nicht alles ist da also sie sind auch ein paar andere sachen hier habe ich noch
Wobei nie das ist auch so ein prime day
so ein prime detail
Und die steckdose vom letzten mal der raspberry pi der sick be stick das
Thermostat das ding für die heizung und noch ein paar andere sachen ich habe hier unten hier unten es sieht ja nicht so auf der
Seite habe ich auch noch ein paar sachen stehen
Was wir ausprobieren müssen und zwar ich habe hier beim prime day ein paar sachen bestellt wo ich mir dachte preisleistungstechnisch in der kombination ganz
Nice ich bin mir aber nicht sicher ob sie gescheit mit sick be funktionieren ich mache das noch in titel
Und ich zeige euch ich zeige euch auch gleich was ich was ich am start habe alles
Zumindest müssen wir ausprobieren ob das funktioniert also wie gesagt ich habe mir so einen stick wobei es ist es ist ja gar
Kein reiner sick be stick das steht auch hier irgendwo
Nein das steht nicht hier drauf
Ne steht tatsächlich nicht drauf aber das macht nix das ist ein sick be
schrägstrich thread stick
also er kann thread und sick be
Wobei ist thread nicht irgendwas auf der gleichen frequenz wie sick be und hat das irgendwie teilweise sogar übernommen
Ach keine ahnung ich blicke nicht durch
Any primers ja der ist der erste primer am start gamepad dankeschön
underscore
Pogpad
Nice subscriptions
Ist thread noch ein ding oder ist das tot ich dachte eigentlich dass das der neue angesagte kram ist
Mit meta zusammen thread ist quasi so das layer 2 protokoll und und meta ist so das logische obendrüber
Ich dachte eigentlich dass thread immer noch angesagt weiß ich nicht genau ich habe mich damit jetzt schon
Bestimmt die letzten bestimmt das letzte halbe jahr oder so mich nicht mal großartig mit beschäftigt
Weil ich sehe es aktuell nicht ein die sachen zu ersetzen die ich habe
Und und viele hersteller sind halt immer noch so auf dem sick be zug
Also die großen threads
Produkte sehe ich bis jetzt noch nicht
Meta meta war eher der hype thread nicht wirklich meta obendrüber wobei ich halt ehrlich sagen muss so wirklich gebraucht
Hat es auch keiner
Viele hersteller haben ihr sick be zeug schon so gemacht dass ich es gut integrieren lässt und sie wave war ja von haus aus so dass
Es alles per speck miteinander kompatibel war
Per speck miteinander kompatibel war warum suhme ich eigentlich die ganze zeit hierum per emote
Egal lassen wir lassen einfach weiter summen
Also ich weiß auch nicht was da was da abgeht zumindest zumindest der stick kann
Es steht es steht nicht da guck ich weiß ich ob ihr das erkennt also steht bloß sick be drauf ich muss mal kurz warten
Bis da bis die forscher ein bisschen runter
Ich weiß nicht ob man es jetzt auf dem kleinen forscher bild erkennt da steht nur sick be drauf aber offiziell hat dieser stick
Z hier guck
Z b dongle p so
Und der kann hier sonoff
Und der kann angeblich auch thread zumindest stand das
Zumindest stand das bei amazon drauf will bilde ich mir ein dass das dass das drauf stand
pepo please
Hier ach moment geht das nur
Ach, vielleicht geht es auch nur mit dem minus e
Es kann auch sein dass es nur mit dem minus e geht
Blickt auch keiner durch
Keck wait
Ist es aber auch nicht so wild weil ich werde den ähnlich benutzen für mein live system oder höchstwahrscheinlich nicht für mein live system
Also mein sick bezeugt hat sich noch nicht einmal in all den jahren aufgehängt
Also jetzt jetzt gar nicht irgendwie schön umschrieben so weil ich ich reboote öfters und sowas ich reboote meine kiste nie
Und sick be hat sich noch nie aufgehängt das geht einfach
Ich habe allerdings auch letztlich so wahnsinnig viele geräte im sick be drinne
67 stück oder so
Das meiste das meiste sind
Also eigentlich sind fenstersensoren aber ich benutze die auch fürs hoftau und sowas also open close sensoren thermo thermostat
Noch was sind da noch drinne
also 67 dinger
Fällt mir jetzt gar nichts mehr ein vielleicht sind es auch nur die zwei gerätetypen die nicht können es müssen können nicht können nicht sein
Ach ja ganz vergessen schalter habe ich noch so ein so ein so ein so ein so ein sechsfach schalter stimmt schalter ist noch drin
Und das hat sich noch nie also wirklich noch nie
aufgehängt
Sven supreme dankeschön für den sub
ne
Als würde ich mich damit irgendwie beschäftigen
Ist reddit down weil keine comments geladen werden we had a server error fünf comments
ist reddit dead
Probieren wir mal old reddit
Warum geht einfach old reddit und der andere kram geht nicht im moment minus e das ist ja der minus p stick
Wie dem auch sei ich will damit der esig wie machen
ohne sick be
Wie heißt der kerl noch mal
Paul irgendwas ohne sick be
Reddit knallt schon ein ja ich habe heute morgen ein video gesehen auf twitter von irgendwie einer
Schulklasse oder so da ist eine mit dem handy durchgelaufen das hatten er hatte irgendwie von
Von 10 notebooks hat einen neuen subreddit place offen
Ah ja und dann müssen wir noch also ich erzähle euch mal was was heute angesagt ist ich schalte mal kurz auf die kamera um
Also also chat geht noch mal was dazu wie gesagt ich benutze als sick be hardware ein kombi 2 seit jahren schon
Weiß ich
Kombi 2 release date das ist ja auch schon nicht mehr der neueste stick der kam
2015 oder irgendwie so raus
Na guckt die haben sogar schon 2019 irgendwelche sagen also das ist das 2015 vielleicht nicht ist jetzt übertrieben 2018 oder so
Also ist auf jeden fall schon ein bisschen älter das teil
Und jetzt habe ich mir jetzt so ein bisschen auszuprobieren den den den sonoff stick gekauft der aber moderner ist
Das ist ja auch so ein ding
Der offizielle reddit klein ist übelst nervig der ist viel besser geworden die letzten jahre über aber das immer noch ultra nervig
Zum beispiel den neueste neueste trend wenn irgendwas screenshot ist von reddit
Dann fragt ich reddit ob du das sie scheren möchtest und sowas richtig nervig
Okay ich switche mal kurz rüber auf die kamera
Ein bisschen leiser machen
Okay, also ich switche mal kurz rüber auf die kamera ich zeige euch mal ich zeige was wir heute am start haben also
So dass wir was mal ausprobieren werden zwar folgendes oh ich muss mal hier
Erst mal die das kabel bisschen aus dem weg machen
also
Holkendes
Chatterinos guckt mal her also ich habe einmal wieder
Alt gediente raspberry pi 4 am start den den ich glaube das ist ein
Könnte sogar ein 8 gigabyte modell sein
Da war es mir mal irgendwie danach keine ahnung was ich mir da was ich mir dabei gedacht habe ein preis leistungsmäßig unsinnig dafür
Ja raspberry pi da haben wir gleich home assistant auf die sd karte drauf übrigens absicht an der stelle jetzt absicht dass ich keine
ssd nehme
Aber leckt das video ein bisschen
Testen hier
löst eigentlich relativ
Doch das ist ein bisschen als würden da ein oder anderen frames getroppt werden gut kann jetzt nichts kann jetzt nicht
dran ändern
Das ist manchmal weil ich habe die ich halte dass es ein iphone hier oben was aufnimmt und das ist auch nur per wlan drin das
Sagt ich wie gesagt wenn wir solche streams hier öfters machen habe ich am letzten bastel stream gesagt da werde ich mir mal eine ordentliche
Kamera kaufen kann nicht sein dass man das iphone für für
Da missbrauchen muss was macht denn das hier eigentlich
Okay an dem slider sollte ich mal besser nicht rumdrehen
Das das war der falsche slider
Was passiert wenn ich mein handy mal auf 60 fps hochstelle von 50 geht es dann besser
60 fps frame rate mismatch kommt jetzt okay ist es jetzt schlecht frame rate mismatch
Aber ich ich habe irgendwie das gefühl jetzt ist jetzt ist flüssig doch nicht
Oder ich stelle wieder 50 wieso überträgst du das nicht das video per kabel
Weil ich dann ein usb kabel bräuchte von hier von hier rüber irgendwie zu meinem rechner und das ist einfach angenehmer
Wenn ich das per wlan machen kann
Hast du bei den milf rast noch mal geguckt ob usb steuerbar ist ich glaube nicht selber aber nachher ausprobieren
Ja habe ich das hier habe ich das teil ja also ich zeige euch mal kurz was wir am start haben also wie gesagt der raspberry
Pi 4 ist am start da kommt homo system drauf ja genau und wir werden es nicht mit ssd machen ich habe zwar einige
Usb ssd adapter und ich habe auch per externen usb also per externen usb ssd aber wisst ihr was der grund ist warum ich es nicht
Per usb ssd mache und zwar weil ich mir nicht sicher bin
Wie viel sich der usb stick genehmigt und bevor das ganze noch an stabil wird das hatte ich beispielsweise mit dem tv stick schon mal
Dann ist der raspberry pi immer abgekackt weil die ssd kurzzeitig mit nicht genug spannung versorgt wurde also insofern
Machen wir es mal lieber mit eingebauter micro sd karte ist es jetzt ein wenig so als wird es großartig problematisch sein dafür
Ja okay und dann aber hier den sonoff stick ich packe das ding ich packe das ding mal aus mal gucken wie das ausschaut
Super
so
Also das ist einer mit so ein bisschen ein bisschen passiv passiv kühler guck hier der sick be
Wie sieht es heute mit scharfstellen aus eigentlich iphone geht das heute besser als das letzte mal
Naja eher sick be usb dongle hinten kann man anscheinend die batterie nicht die batterie
Die antenne dran machen okay
Denken wir schon mal ist das ein usb
Es ist ein sick be 3.0 dongle aber ist es auch ein usb 3.0 dongle es ist weiß von der idee her sollte es
Usb 2 sein wir stecken wir stecken es trotzdem ein usb 3 man weiß man weiß ja nie
So dann schließen wir schließen wir an die netzwerkkabel mache ich mache ich dann ich mache das auch noch mal raus genau also haben wir den
sick be stick
War mal die verpackung war mal die verpackung weg
Direkt direkt in müll
Porke dann haben wir die steckdose vom letzten mal
Erinnert sich vielleicht noch ein oder andere dran der der gute allseits bekannte hersteller milfra
Machst du home assistant mit docker? Nein ich mache home assistant ohne docker ich mache home assistant os
direkt auf den raspberry pi drauf
Was ich finde auch der die bessere installation ist für so einen für so ein anwendungsfall dann kann man nämlich addons und sowas benutzen
Übrigens ein problem bei der steckdose ist guck mal auf der seite gar kein problem ihr seht es ja
Alles top wie neu ja kein ding aber auf der seite
Erkennt ihr es das hat leider ein bisschen gelitten beim aufmachen
Und das problem dabei ist dass ich irgendwie den schließmechanismus gekillt habe das heißt wenn man jetzt zu fest hier dran zieht
dann
Also nichts was ich wirklich dauerhaft benutzen würde
Aber zum aus also das heißt da muss man wirklich vorsichtig sein wenn man es aufmacht oder aber oder aber
Eine eine runde heiß klebern geht natürlich auch nicht
Eine runde heiß klebern geht natürlich auch immer
Aber wir lassen das wir lassen das jetzt so zum testen zum testen ist das vollkommen in ordnung
weil also
Was ich ausprobieren will ist folgendes also wir machen die home assistant drauf dann gucken wir wie das mit dem neuen zigby dongle
Funktioniert wir verwenden höchstwahrscheinlich zigby to äh ne
MQTT to zigby ne zigby to MQTT verwenden wir deswegen ist auch ein weiterer punkt warum home assistant
Nicer ist da kann man das nämlich direkt als add-on drauf machen
Und der unterstützt einfach immer noch mehr geräte als dieses eingebaute zigby zeug in home assistant
dann müssen wir hier das tast motor über
Wlan integrieren in home assistant auch mal gucken wie das mit den neueren versionen geht bei mir ist es ja ein bisschen
Outdated was ich habe dann habe ich mir den allerneuesten akara ist auch ist entweder wlan oder zigby da bin ich mir jetzt nicht
Ganz sicher müssen wir mal schauen wenn das wlan ist dann probieren wir es heute nicht aus
Schauen schauen wir mal die neuesten akara presence detection sensor bestellt presence sensor fp2
Gab's günstig beim prime day
Und das ding ist richtig nice
Das kann wenn man das also das ist nicht ein so ein einfacher presence detection sensor wie man das kennt so nach dem motto von
Bewegungserkennung im flur oder so nee das ist viel advance da der kann sogar
Ich weiß nicht funktioniert das funktioniert so ein bisschen radarmäßig
Der kann sogar wenn du das ding ins wohnzimmer hängst kann der sogar erkennen wo du im wohnzimmer sitzt bis zu fünf leute kann das
glaube ich tracken also kannst zum beispiel wenn du wenn du einfach nur durchs wohnzimmer läuft und
Sagen wir mal den rollo hoch und runter machst dann passiert nix aber wenn du dich auf sofa setzt für zehn sekunden
Dann geht der fernseher automatisch an und solche geschichten das kann man damit machen also sprich der kann im raum
Orten wo die leute sich gerade befinden was super nice ist mal gucken ob es funktioniert ich bin mir nicht sicher vielleicht es ist
Wi-Fi weil dann muss ich es mit dem tablet einrichten und das wird mir dann im stream zu kompliziert ohne dass ich irgendwas leake
Aber dann probieren wir das vielleicht das nächste mal aus wenn ich es eingerichtet habe weil es muss ja auch in home assistant integriert werden
Raspberry pi sind immer noch ziemlich teuer ja
Aber aber deutlich günstiger als noch vor ein paar monaten also raspberry pi sind mittlerweile würde ich sagen so
Ja die haben ja mal teilweise dass das vier- und fünffache gekostet jetzt kosten sie
Jetzt kosten sie sagen wir mal knapp das doppelte vielleicht so
Vielleicht auch nur so 60 70 prozent also das was ich 45 euro sollte es normal kosten jetzt kostet
80 oder so aber die sind immer noch ziemlich teuer aber mittlerweile mittlerweile geht das halbwegs ja nicht mehr 280 euro für so ein raspberry
Pi 4 die sind die waren ja komplett von allen guten geistern verlassen so dann haben wir noch ein paar andere sachen die ich ausprobieren
Wollte mit zigby und zwar ich habe mir so ein
Ein thermostat gekauft für die heizung da habe ich schon welche ich plane ehrlich gesagt zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht
Das ganze einzusetzen aber das gab es sehr günstig beim prime day und ich habe mir
gedacht ich probiere es einfach mal aus ob das was taugt
Offiziell geht das nicht mit zigby sondern nur mit der offiziellen bosch bridge und ganz ehrlich da habe ich keinen bock drauf
Aber ich habe gleichermaßen gelesen dass mit zigby to mqtt in verbindung mit home assistant das mittlerweile doch unterstützt wird
Das heißt das will ich mal ausprobieren weil wie gesagt zum prime day gab es die dinger super günstig
Zumal es halt auch so ein ding ist ich glaube niemand kauft sich bosch home automation zeug ja
Die dinger sind meistens einfach nur so ein bisschen wie philips hue philips hue ist halt der übelste verkaufsschlager obwohl es viel viel mehr
Also muss ich umgedreht sein obwohl es eigentlich viel zu teuer ist und die meisten leute gar keine rgb lampen überhaupt brauchen aber gut
Also da bin ich gespannt ob es das ob das das hier unterstützt bin wirklich
sehr gespannt drauf
Ich habe bei mir im haus zwar solche dinge aber nicht von bosch ich habe seit einer ganzen weile
Schon so fritz deckt thermostate für die heizung die
Die fritz thermostate sind in der tat gar nicht übel
Die halten relativ lang so eine halb zwei jahre mit den batterien
Also mal eher eineinhalb jahre
Mit den batterien sind ansonsten aber super zuverlässig einziger nachteil ist
Also bei den fritz thermostaten jetzt die schalten ein bisschen lahm also wenn du jetzt abschickst
Dass das hochdrehen soll die heizung dann kann es bis zu 15 minuten dauern dass die anfangen das liegt einfach daran
Das deckt zu viel strom verbrauchen würde wenn es zu oft polt also deswegen polen diese diese
Fritz thermostate nur alle viertel stunde nach neuen werten was aber wenn man automatisiert sein haus
Ja
Aber ab 18 uhr machen wir im wohnzimmer warm im winter weil die leute dann bald fernsehgucken gehen oder so was dann ist es kein
Problem so auf schnelle sachen zu reagieren sind die fritz thermostate nicht so gut mal gucken wie das ist
Dann haben wir den aquara den akara presence detection sensor
Sparen wird man da vermutlich nicht viel nee also ich bin der meinung die die leute die erzählen ja
Heimautomatisierung ist ganz toll weil man da so viel sparen kann ich glaube die rechnen absichtlich
nicht ganz ehrlich
Also man kann natürlich potenziell was sparen aber wenn man sich überlegt was man sich alles anschaffen muss dafür damit man überhaupt erst mal anfangen
Kann zu sparen musst du verdammt lange sparen dass du das wieder rein hast und wahrscheinlich in der zwischenzeit das ding schon kaputt
Also ja du wirst wahrscheinlich wirklich ein paar euro im jahr sparen durch automatische steuerung der heizung
aber wenn du dir überlegst dass du dass du
mindestens 60 euro pro heizung
Pro heizkörper ausgeben muss um den smart zu machen und dann auch irgendeine zentrale für brauchst also das heißt
Du bist bist mindestens mal
350 euro los für für fünf für fünf
heizkörper und ein bisschen steuerung
Eher 400 euro bis zu 400 euro gespart hast an heizkosten das ist schon
Nicht so realistisch in kurzer zeit bis dahin ist wahrscheinlich wieder kaputt es ist eher komfort als geld sparen so
Der max hat übrigens nicht mehr so dicke finger wie früher falls euch aufgefallen ist so dann habe ich noch
Ach ja muss ich euch auch zeigen also steckdose milfra habe ich mir auch der beste name
Und dann habe ich noch was was ich auch mal gucken will wie gut sich das mittlerweile ein home assistant integriert weil meine
Home assistant integration ist auch schon ein paar versionen alt sowohl die home assistant integration
Als auch die software und zwar ich habe hier vor einer ganzen weile mal eine lampe eine lampe gebaut guckt mal
das ist
Weiß ich ob man das richtig erkennt habe ich eine lampe gebaut
Das ist nach einer
3d also das 3d gedrucktes 3d gedrucktes gehäuse ist eigentlich ist eigentlich sehr nice ich glaube das ist nach einer vorlage von
Bitluni war das glaube ich auf youtube falls den channel jemand kennt ich glaube es war bitluni es könnte auch
könnte auch was anderes gewesen sein
So jetzt habe ich habe ich eine lampe hier 3d gedruckt
Und da ist man sieht sich habe unten nicht zu gemacht man sieht vielleicht ein bisschen was da drin ist
Da ist so eine 16 x 16 led matrix drinne
und ein
Ja wenn man glück hat sieht man es ein bisschen ja ihr seht die pins
Da ist ein esp 286 d1 mini drinne und wenn man das anschließt
schließt das mal kurz an
Dann dann leuchtet es sieht ein bisschen kacke mit der kamera aus wenn das so nah dran ist aber
Es diffuset ein bisschen so hier es sieht in echt besser aus als durch die kamera
Genau und das will ich da läuft wedel drauf
und ich will mal gucken
Wie gut sich aktuell wedel und die neue wedel integration in home assistant anfühlt müssen wir auch mal ausprobieren
Das heißt dass wir das versuchen wir alles mal zu integrieren in home assistant hauptsächlich geht es mir heute ums ikbi und um das thermostat dahinten
Dann habe ich noch ein paar andere dinger die ich schon seit einer weile mal ausprobieren wollte in sie über sie und zwar
Das ist so eine nette spielerei ich weiß echt nicht wofür man es braucht
Zwar ist von akara das habe ich mal alles bei aliexpress bestellt also das hier das hier und das hier
habe ich mal bei aliexpress bestellt da habe ich mal irgendwie so ein 30er pack china chinesen sick bezeugt bestellt und zwar das ist ein
akara
Was steht da muss man das bosch noch flashen nee das kannst du nicht flashen wir können nur hoffen dass mit sick b2m qtd das funktioniert
Ja, also ich weiß nicht ob irgendjemand von euch entziffern kann china chinesen kram das ist so einen würfel und
Den kann man nicht ach hier ist doch glaube ich hier steht es doch hier sieht man es neben guck mal wenn du das rotierst
löst das kannst du damit verschiedene
Automationen auslösen
Mal gucken ich glaube es ist einfach unsinnige spielerei aber ihr seht das ist noch original verpackt und ich habe das schon seit zwei jahren oder
So ich wollte es mal ausprobieren ob das ob das was taugt vielleicht kann man das ja für irgendwas benutzen
Ja, und dann habe ich auch ein fernseher sensor original verpackt ein paar
Thermostate die wollte ich einfach mal ausprobieren ob das hier alles ordentlich unterstützt wird mit dem sick b stick
Ja, also ich glaube ich kann das ja auch mal ausprobieren
Ja, und dann habe ich auch ein fernseher sensor original verpackt ein paar
Thermostate die wollte ich einfach mal ausprobieren ob das hier alles ordentlich unterstützt wird mit dem sick b stick
Ja, das war es das werden wir jetzt ausprobieren. Wofür ich hier die ganzen usb sticks rumliegen habe weiß ich nicht die brauchen wir heute nicht
Wled ist ein webserver für den esp
Ja, so ungefähr also wled ist eine custom firmware für den esp
Mit unter anderem einem webinterface aber auch integrationsmöglichkeiten direkt in home assistant und sonst was ist eigentlich ganz cool
Kannst du mal ein video über dein gesamtes smart home machen ja wollte ich schon seit jahren mal machen
Aber ein bf1 video gesehen wurde zu sehen war das ja kann schon sein
Ich bin in paar videos geleakt worden aber es hat nie so einer richtig gecheckt
Philips hue ist nicht verkehrt aber philips hue ist teuer und weit über dem was die meisten leute brauchen
Also ich habe es ja schon öfters gesagt die meisten leute brauchen bei rgb leds eigentlich gar kein rgb
Die meisten leute brauchen was was man smart mäßig ein- und ausschalten kann und eventuell dimmen kann die nächste stufe ist
farb
Wie heißt es noch mal?
Farbtemperatur einzustellen also quasi ob es rötlicher ist oder oder also
weiß weißer oder oder rötlicher
Da brauchst du auch keine rgb led und erst danach rgb und die meisten leute brauchen an
90 95 prozent der stellen keine rgb leds
die weil sie die die die meisten leute wollen ja nicht lila einschalten sondern die wollen
die led dim ein
Ausschalten und und vielleicht ein bisschen die farbtemperatur ändern aber es jetzt irgendwie grün lila blau und so machen wollen die meisten ja gar nicht
Ja ja ja aber du kennst die leute wenn wir die auswahl haben zwischen super advance
Dann kaufen die lieber super advance wenn sie schon haben und viele leute haben rgb am start an stellen wo sie kein rgb
Brauchen und das philips youzeug ist auch mit den normalen bieren schon teuer genug
Also ich bin da kein allzu großer fan von das beste was man machen kann ist seine normalen klüge behalten und die
Eigentlichen schalter smart machen wenn es einem nur uns ein wenn es einem nur um ein- und ausschalten geht
Dann hat man nämlich auch den vorteil dass die schalter an der wand noch funktionieren
Was sonst ja oftmals probleme macht weil dann darfst du nicht mehr ausschalten weil ansonsten hat die klüge
Kein strom mehr und deswegen kannst du nicht mehr smart ausschalten
Ja sehe ich genau so finde ich auch am sinnvollsten
Irgendwelche shellys oder irgendwelche wie heißen die anderen
Bit oder so
Kubik oder so gibt es noch andere hersteller die sowas machen da gibt es da gibt es quasi relays die man einbauen kann
in den in den schalter quasi und dann schaltest du nicht mehr direkt
Deine lampe an der decke sondern du schaltest quasi den microcontroller der schalte die decke und er kann aber auch die decke schalten ohne den knopf zu drücken
Ja haben die glaube ich noch ja
Relativ
Sicher haben die das noch so jetzt müssen wir erstmal unser raspberry pi flashen
das heißt ich gehe mal kurz hierüber mache meine vm an
und
Wir updaten die vm
Ich hoffe dass man
Meine meine lampe hier
hoffe ich dass sie sich noch im wlan an ein lockt sonst muss ich die irgendwie anmelden noch noch extra
also pac-man
Erst mal eine runde packages updaten ja wohl leading edge arch by the way
Also hier los
nix gut
reboot
gut dann brauchen wir mal die sd karte
Sd karte sd karten reader
Und dann flashen wir jetzt erst mal das aktuelle home assistant os drauf
Ich überlege gerade mein dev setup für die arbeit entweder in wsl 2 und defcontainer umzuziehen vor allem weil es leider nicht
Sagt bei dir halt so ein bisschen wie bei mir ich bei mir ist im endeffekt auch so ich habe ein windows notebook aber zum
Glück eine ordentliche vm wo ich gut drauf bin aber über die kann ich mich auch nur mit einem terminal einloggen
Ich werde die aber noch ein bisschen nerven vielleicht gibt es ja irgendwann mal linux clients
Ich gehe in die nächsten jahre richtig krass auf den sack noch sage ich euch
so
blub blub blub blub stream
sagt
Gucken ob der mein usb stick erkannt hat
Sdb perfekt home assistant pi download
ja
install home assistant operating system
Ach moment der pi imager hat es direkt dabei
das ist ja nice
Der pi imager hat es mittlerweile direkt drin
jepp kock ok ne hat er gar nicht stimmt nicht fake news
ach ne moment
Wo muss ich hin
Other specific purpose
Os
Ihr home assistant automations homosexuell tatsächlich mega nice
Ja, ich habe kein browser installiert linux nein gar kein fall
nice
Das ist ja cool dass sie das mittlerweile direkt eingebaut haben in dem imager
Probezeit schon vorbei in den noch drei na zwei monate zwei monate noch
Home assistant us raspberry pi 4
True storage data right yes, let's go ich bin übelst lange gelaufen leute
Ich überlege gerade kilometer heute mittag sieben kilometer und heute morgen ja wahrscheinlich ein bisschen weniger
Dafür war es heute morgen deutlich hügel licher
Heute morgen lasst es mal heute morgen
5,56 gewesen sein also wenn ich da drüben auf den 13 kilometer gelaufen hat
Ich bin auch ein bisschen im arsch
Aber nach einer woche nur noch vom computer hocken bringt es ist das wirklich mal sehr angenehm
Am wochenende sich auch ein bisschen mehr zu bewegen ich weiß hätte ich mir das selbst gesagt vor 15 jahren hätte ich gesagt sagt max
halt die klappe wen juckt
Aber ich sage euch seitdem ich angefangen habe jeden tag eineinhalb stunden
Ja, so ungefähr eineinhalb stunden mich zu bewegen ich habe keinen kopfweh mehr keine rückenschmerzen mehr keine kreislauf nichts mehr
Hast du extra wanderschuhe
Ob ich nicht ganz normale turnschuhe an aber
Witzig witzig dass du es anspricht ich bin mir überlegen wanderschuhe zu kaufen ich habe jetzt schon ein paar videos geguckt
also es wird wahrscheinlich was sehr leichtes werden weil ich
kletter nicht und
Das meiste ist auch komplett befestigt wo ich laufe also jetzt keine irgendwie abschüssigen
So splits wege oder so also wahrscheinlich wird es irgendwas leichtes werden aber zumindest was mit ein bisschen
Griffigeren sohle als meine turnschuhe die ich aktuell habe also wahrscheinlich werde ich mir wanderschuhe holen aber aktuell
ohne wanderschuhe nur turnschuhe
Im urlaub eine alpentour
Du hast dir vor drei jahren ein fahrrad
Ergometer gekauft was ist das das wo man sieht wie viel watt wie viel watt man tritt oder was
Läufst du über einen park oder in einem wald oder eher auf der straße
Also es ist kein park
Es ist wald
Aber es ist auch straße und und feldweg ich zeige dir mal eine runde wo ich beispielsweise gerne laufe
Habe ich euch ja schon mal gezeigt
Aber eine runde eine runde wo ich gerne laufe ist zum beispiel hier dass man sich mal ungefähr vorstellen kann
membris
Ups was jetzt wo ist das zugegangen hier laufe ich ganz gerne
hat schon hat schon ein paar hügel
Ich laufe dann meistens
Die warten jetzt auf mich also das ist das jetzt zum beispiel eine runde die ich gerne laufe guck von hier unten
Moment wo ist die straße hier
Hier ist die straße genau ja von von hier hier ist ein parkplatz hier kann man halten von hier hier lang
Hier lang hier laufe ich lang hier lang hier lang dann darunter
Dann hier hoch
Dann hier durchs
Hier durchs ort
Und hier sieht man es nicht richtig aber dann quasi hier durch den wald wieder wieder zurück
Das ist mega nice runde
Es ist ein bisschen hügelig ich glaube man sieht es man sieht es hier ganz gut wenn man
Wenn da ein bisschen heran zoomt und sich mal umdreht
Guck also bis hier ein bisschen hügelig ist es schon das sind jetzt da sind jetzt keine schweizer alpen oder sowas aber
Bisschen ich glaube der höchste berg hier ist irgendwie 450 meter oder sowas
Also siehst du ein bisschen bisschen berg hoch geht es da auch
Ja also im prinzip man ich laufe von hier unten los und laufe halt diese runde hier
Auf dann halt diese diese runde ja
Das stimmt übrigens überhaupt nicht weil ich euch hier hier hier jetzt diese runde hier so
Das ist das ist so eine die ich beispielsweise besonders gern laufe und ja das ist ein bisschen wald ein bisschen feldweg ein bisschen straße
Und ein bisschen hügel auf der anderen seite ist genauso nice hier hier rüber
Es sieht auch wirklich nett aus wenn man ein bisschen aussicht haben wir so ein alter steinbruch mit dem see
Gibt es hier so eine aussicht und aussicht plattform wo man rüber gucken kann
So und dass das hier ist so in der nähe ist so in der gegend so der höchste
Höchste höchste berg da ist dann auch so
Genau da ist dann hier auch so ein turm genau da das ist so eine ecke wo ich öfters unterwegs bin liegt ja
das ist ungefähr
Ja, ich würde sagen so 5,5 oder 6 kilometer meter am start
Jedo danke für den sub huge subscription
Ich frage mich ernsthaft ich habe mich jetzt schon eine weile wie funktionieren diese teile
Also das sind ja so dinger die dir anzeigen wie viel wie viel watt du gerade an leistung da auf dem fahrrad trittst
Wie geht das weil rein mit dem drehen der räder von der geschwindigkeit her kann das ja nicht sein
Weil wenn du weil wenn du berghoch fährst
Dann ist das viel viel brutaler aber die bewegung halt gering
Magnet bremse
Okay keine ahnung wie das funktionieren soll okay aber
Ich meine es funktioniert die profis verwenden das ja auch
Ihr l-stream wollt ihr mal eine stunde mit mir durch den wald rennen ja rennen ich renne ja nicht wirklich durch den wald
Wollt ihr mal mit mir eine stunde durch den wald flitzen
Liegt so wo sind wir jetzt stehen geblieben chat hat er jetzt geflasht continue
Fertig geflasht okay nice
dann
Machen wir mal den sd karten reader raus schalten hier mal um das geht übrigens auch mit irgendeinem mit irgendeinem hotkey umzuschalten
Ich weiß aber nicht mit welchem hotkey lasst mich mal kurz gucken hotkeys
Switch to
ziehen
Windows umschalt f2
windows umschalt f1
Okay probier mal windows umschalt f1 und windows ah okay nice
Exzellent sozusagen
Schaltet es jetzt auch wieder zurück
Ist sehr cool ja gut zu wissen
Gut dann starten wir mal den raspberry pi und gucken was abgeht das jetzt funktioniert
Ich muss nebenbei meinen dhcp server aufmachen und gucken
Was wir für eine ip kriegen
der cp server
expires
Okay auf geht's
Schauen wir mal
so
Sdk ich kann mir immer nicht merken wie rum die sd karte reinkommt. Oh, ich habe es geschafft first try
Normalerweise kriege ich das nie first try hin
Aber mal anderes kabel
Raspberry pi ist an ich muss noch mal schnell
den stecker vom netzwerk kabel drinne
und jetzt gucken wir mal
Bin ich mal gespannt also es müsste irgendeine interne ip kriegen ich muss mal kurz auf meine dhcp lises gucken
kann gerade nicht in chat schauen
an string
Ja usb stick war aber dann auch dran
Also direkt mit 130 angefangen ne habe ich nicht
Irgendwie taucht hier kein es taucht kein raspberry pi auf bei mir ja ich habe schon home assistant drauf
Ne
Ist ein mikrotik router das ich gerade gemeldet hat home assistant ja das ist mein
Mein anderer home assistant der sich gerade meldet
Ist er denn macht das noch was das ding ja da blinkt wie verrückt also schauen wir mal ob der jetzt bootet
Ich hoffe doch mal hier ist er home assistant habe ihn spooky musik
Ja okay das dauert immer ein bisschen nicht https
3123 ist home assistant glaube
Okay brauche noch ein bisschen das dauert einfach noch ein bisschen bis es gebootet ist
So also kann ich was dazu sagen hast du direkt bei eineinhalb stunden angefangen oder hast dich eigentlich das ne habe ich nicht
Weniger angefangen und ich bin auch nicht
teilweise samstag zweimal eineinhalb stunden
rumgelaufen
Also ich habe angefangen
Weil ich festgestellt habe dass ich zunehmend immer mehr kopfschmerzen hatte rückenprobleme
Kreislaufsachen und so habe ich mir das kann nicht sein dass man mit 30 schon so im arsch ist ich muss mich ein bisschen mehr
Bewegen ja dann habe ich angefangen erst dass ich in frankfurt von der arbeit damals immer zum südbahnhof gelaufen bin anstatt zum hauptbahnhof
Das war aber nicht so dass ja das hat es nicht groß gebracht
Und irgendwann bin ich dann einfach nachmittags ein bisschen bei uns am main rum gelaufen das war aber auch mega langweilig
und dann bin ich irgendwann auf die idee gekommen und haben gesagt hier fahr doch einfach mittags mal irgendwie so eine so 20 minuten bisschen
ein bisschen
So in die landschaft raus und lauft darum und das hat mir dann viel mehr spaß gemacht so ein bisschen
Bisschen so über über über hügel drüber über wie über felder drüber ein bisschen durch den wald das einfach ein bisschen abwechslung
Und ja das habe ich dann auch nicht jeden tag gemacht
Und irgendwann habe ich mich weil es mir auch bock gemacht hat habe ich mich jetzt gesteigert dass ich jetzt quasi wirklich jeden tag
Eineinhalb mindestens eine halb stunden also auch nachmittags nach der arbeit und so noch samstag sogar manchmal zweimal eineinhalb stunden einmal vormittags einmal nachmittags
ein bisschen
Mich draußen bewege ich dann mal eineinhalb stunden über berg und tal flitze
Und das mache ich wirklich jeden tag außer
Manchmal sonntags nicht aber ansonsten jeden tag
durchgängig
Ohne ausnahme egal wie scheiße das wetter ist
Okay, ja weil wir gleich sehen
So was macht noch muss es mittlerweile da da sind wir preparing home assistant was taking up to 20 minutes
Okay, was machen die dann da?
Du du du du du du du du du du du
Was was der ist wie verrückt am blinken und guckt mal weiß ich ob ich das keine ahnung ob ihr das seht aber
Ist ganz schön
Der ist ganz schön im ppga modus da
Also erkennt man das in der kamera
irgendwie die
leds näher
durch sich umschalten
das ganze am abgehen
Glaubt so sieht man es besser oder auch nicht
Glaubt das ringleit hier oben ist einfach zu hell
St. Karten sind nicht die schnellsten das aber sind aber ganz gute st. Karten sind samsung endurance pro st. Karten
Die gehen nicht so einfach kaputt
Aber natürlich trotzdem nicht zu vergleichen mit der ssd sagt klar
Residenz lieber
Es dauert aber ich habe da noch nie 20 minuten drauf gewartet leute
Jetzt ohne spaß jetzt aber 20 minuten
Das war ich immer instant am start
Muss aber auch sagen ich habe es lange nicht mal auf dem raspberry pi mit sd karte betrieben
Macht der dann jetzt drei stunden
Ihr wisst wie das ist wie bei allen webs umso mehr man refresh umso schneller geht
Wie geht es bis jetzt gut ist noch nichts kaputt gegangen noch nix monka smoke abgeraucht oder sonst was
Einzige sachen die mir ein bisschen sorgen macht ist dass der dass meine steckdose kaputt ist und wenn ich da dran ziehe dann
Kann man hier neben reingucken
Also wie gesagt die werden wir nicht die werde ich nicht dauerhaft betreiben das nummer zum testweise einbinden
Ist er fertig blinken ne blinkt es blinkt sich immer noch ein ab
Du du du du du du du du du du komm wir pingen ihn zusätzlich auch noch mal an
Leute
Also man muss ja sagen
In der berufsschule hatten wir schon so ein paar richtig cringe leute
Da hatten wir als thema irgendwie mal ihr ddos attacken und sonst was und da kam dann wirklich einer auf die idee ich zeige euch
Das jetzt mal da kam es wieder richtig krasses der hacker man vor
Der hat sich dann eine ip von irgendeiner kiste hier in seinem netz rausgesucht und dann hat er so gemacht
Dann hat er so gemacht guckt ha ha ping auf das ha ha
Richtig richtig ja du als würde das irgendjemand schocken wenn das ding jetzt acht mal pink
Das ist das das siehst du noch nicht mal in irgendeinem netzwerk diagramm überhaupt so unbedeutend ist das
Ja mensch home assistant auf jetzt mach hinne
ist immer noch wie verrückt am blinken
was das lahme
Aber kann man nix machen
das blöde ist
Umso mehr downtime ich hier gerade habe umso mehr merke ich meine zweimal eineinhalb stunden bewegung heute da werde ich müde
Per ssh die auslastung anschauen ich glaube man hat er rebootet gerade wie es aussieht
Ich glaube du kannst dich noch gar nicht per ssh standardmäßig verbinden wenn du nicht initial mal
User gesetzt hast es kann übrigens sein dass es ohne ssh addon überhaupt nicht möglich ist sich zu verbinden weiß gar nicht
Fertig
Du warst drei stunden waren an ihr
Heute morgen eineinhalb stunden ungefähr und mittag noch mal
Aufgerundet sechs kilometer dafür halt mit mit mit hügel dabei berge darf ich nicht sagen wenn der patrick da ist man sind ja keine berge im schweizer verhältnisse
Und am mittag noch mal so ein bisschen über sieben kilometer hier bei mir in der ecke
Also quasi so
13 kilometer heute das reicht mir genug
so
Ja, ich glaube das war es für heute
So
13 kilometer heute das reicht mir genug
so
Jetzt sind wir wieder da richtig
motiviert der name
admin
1 2 3 4 5 6 ich hoffe ich hoffe der lässt mich das passwort vergeben jetzt
Highly secure passwort best practice passwort
home in amsterdam perfekt da will ich hin
Country war mal germany und vielleicht ist prozent langweilig englisch timezone berlin
Europa berlin darf man nicht suchen
belize
Wenn es berlin und amsterdam nicht die gleiche zeitzone
Ist es nicht
Currency euro euro
Fahrenheit und pounds ja ganz bestimmt ganz bestimmt
Basic analytics usage nein ich will nichts scheren
Nein das will ich auch nicht ändern auch keine bluetooth adapter und sonst was zeug no pass
Finish
Oder hatte das hat er jetzt einfach schon hinzugefügt oder was
Der kleine pp gealter so start with mt. Dashboard wir taken control dann
Gut notifications ja ihr könnt es kaufern wie viel ihr wollt ist settings restarts required
Okay, dann
Hallo restarte mal es ist ja nicht so als habe ich nicht eben schon zweimal gestartet
Die sind komplett lost
meinst die amis
Wieso
Ein kann er in kanada das metrische und imperial system beides zusammen achtung scheiße
Okay die sind wirklich lost
Speed metrisch okay da schon mal gut wenigstens können kommen die da so mit meter pro sekunde und so irgendwie ganz ganz gut klar
distance also
Wenn es um die eigene körperhöhe körpergröße geht dann in imperial
ansonsten
Wenn es eine lange distance ist
No
Ist it related to work?
Yes, dann imperial no metric. What the fuck was ist denn mit denen verkehrt?
Und warum messen die distance in time die darf wie darf man sich das vorstellen
Geben geben die alles in lichtsekunden an oder was ach so 15 minuten bis man da ist und so ja okay
Aber das wird immer um genauer umso länger es ist temperature
Okay
Fahrenheit wenn sie kochen wenn sie nicht kochen wenn es ein pool temperatur ist dann auch fahrenheit wenn ein dann in celsius
okay gewicht
gibt es eigene gewicht
pounds wenn es heavy ist dann in kilogramm wenn es nicht heavy ist dann in pounds
Volumen fürs kochen
Spoons oh gott cups und spoons
Die sind okay die sind wirklich lost in kanada
Da blickst du also
erinnert sich noch einer daran dass man ein modul bei der
Bei der iss nicht richtig gepasst hat
Weil die einen in inches und die anderen in zentimetern gemessen haben so ist das in kanada wahrscheinlich laufend bei allem
Ja btu ist generell die alte die beste einheit überhaupt leute also wenn ich weiß was btu ist
Der hat es eigentlich gut ja dann habt ihr die größte bullshit an dass ich jetzt eigentlich neu gestartet oder nicht
Da habt ihr die größte bullshit einheit wenigstens verpasst
Restart hat okay ja genau weil nur nur zur erklärung btu wenn ich das richtig aus dem kopf zusammen bekomme
Btu ist die energie die man braucht um ein britisches fund
Wasser um ein grad fahrenheit zu erwärmen
Also viel schwachsinn ergeht schwachsinniger geht es glaube ich nicht mehr
Die wärmeenergie die benötigt wird ein britisches fund wasser um ein grad fahrenheit zu erwerben genau
ein btu sind
0 5 5 8 5 2 6 2 jule alles klar gut dass man das so easy umrechnen kann
Das ist das ist der richtige richtig high also low iq 3 hats
Einheit das war ziemlich sicher bei der iss auch nicht zu verwechseln mit ii s
Es ist dieser eklige microsoft webserver
So okay unser home assistant ist am start
overview passt alles gut nice
Nein, dismiss
Map liegt wir sind in amsterdam leute shit was mache ich jetzt
Schnell weg ich hoffe es hat keiner geklebt dann würde ich sagen fangen wir mal an auszuprobieren
Ich würde sagen leute wir fangen easy an
Wir fangen mit der steckdose an oder was was was was meint ihr wir fangen mit der steckdose an
Die wir das letzte mal
geflasht haben
flash champ
Ebenlich mit der hier da
milfra
Ich stöpsel das ganze mal ein ich muss das mal kurz so drehen dass sie irgendwas irgendwas sieht
Also sieht man hier was man hier was ja ich stöpsel das mal rein hier
Okay es leuchtet rot
Das schon mal gut
Das heißt es funktioniert hoffentlich gucken wir noch mal in dhcp server was der sagt
Das motor
138 jawohl
Da sind wir
Passt mal auf das hier ist die steckdose die ich gerade eingesteckt habt milfra 1
An- und ausschalten kann ich
Mal kurz ein bisschen
auch ein bisschen
Ich bewege es noch mal ein bisschen her dass ihr auch was seht jetzt gerade der forscher
An und aus
Ich kann euch sogar zeigen dass das ein- und ausschalten funktioniert machen wir es mal so guckt mal
Muss mal kurz gucken
Ja ich mache jetzt einfach mal ein netzteil rein und das machen wir an die lampe dran das ist das netzteil kann man die spannung
und nein stellen steht auf 5 volt
und
Moment leute ich muss mal kurz hören ob das nicht das ist was kaputt ist
Es sollte nicht meine sicherung rausfliegen ich glaube das kaputte netzteil habe ich weggeschmissen
Ich hatte ich hatte mal so ein ähnliches war kaputt da hat sie mal die sicherung rausgehauen
Weil es schien ab billig schiener chinesen schrott ist ich will jetzt nicht dass die sicherung rausfliegt bei mir
Also von der idee her sollte jetzt folgendes passieren wenn ich hier auf den knopf drücke sollte die lampe angehen
funktioniert
Nein
Jo funktioniert
Nice
Hast du schon den sonoff usb stick geflasht für home assistant moment man muss den flashen
Ich dachte man kann den einfach dran stecken oder funktioniert was das
Wie man muss den flashen monkaS
Aus damit
How to
Okay
Ich hätte gedacht das funktioniert einfach
Ich
Gucke mir mal die einleitung was sich b2m qtt gleich an wenn wir soweit sind
So also das ist das webinterface von der steckdose wir haben das letztens geflasht mit tasmota
13 wir schauen mal kurz was es ob es vielleicht nicht nur eine neuere tasmota version gibt
Das motor 13.0
quasim
Quasim
Was was heißt das eigentlich
Okay keine ahnung in bagdad
Was auch immer
Gut keine ahnung was das uns sagen soll aber anscheinend gibt es nichts neues
Ja natürlich ist es der release name aber
Es ist mir auch klar dass es der release name ist aber ich frage mich was halt dahinter steckt manche mein debian hat toy story character
Immer in ihrem namen ja bookworm zum beispiel sit
wo die gab es satsch
Kann ja sein dass das irgendwas irgendwas bedeuten soll so also wir haben die neueste tasmota version
Jetzt mal gucken wie man das in home assistant integriert das ist schon eine weile her wo ich das gemacht habe das motor home assistant
Home assistant
Mqtt
Okay, also ich glaube man muss einfach nur
Eine integration
hinzufügen für das motor
Und das war es wenn ich das richtig in erinnerung habe das war ganz easy
Du, you want to set up das motor yes
Created configuration finish
das motor fehlt okay
Ach nur die nur die weiß ist okay
at entry
Sehen wir bin ich deutlich zu pp gar keine ahnung wie das funktioniert auch meine mqtt dafür
anscheinend ja
Nein, ich will es nicht per mqtt nutzen aber es kann sein
dass die integration
Mqtt voraussetzt es ist anscheinend so
Dann besser sick b2 mqtt
Hä?
Chatgirt das eine hat doch mit dem anderen nichts zu tun
Das eine ist für sick b2 geräte das andere ist für wi-fi tasmota geräte das eine ist doch überhaupt nichts zu vergleichen mit dem anderen
Okay, also man braucht wohl wirklich
Einen ich will mein shield nicht discoveren kann man das wieder löschen
Okay, dann machen wir jetzt da war jetzt erst mal die
Mqtt moment die mqtt ist in addon
Man sieht ich habe lange kein home assistant mehr vom scratch eingerichtet ach genau ich brauche erst mal das addon
das addon für den broker und bevor wir irgendwas machen gehen wir in meine settings für meinen user und schalten den
Advanced mode ein sonst sieht man nämlich die hälfte nicht
Genau addon was mit der schrift los die schrift ist ziemlich pp gerade würde ich sagen
Mqtt mosquito broker jawohl
Das wollen wir haben official addons mosquito broker
Install
Warum installt das drei stunden
installt das so lang
Wir können ja mal in die logs gucken warum das so lange installiert
Logs
Downloading docker image nöder ist einfach nur
Langsam da ist er doch der war einfach nur lahm
Konfiguration
Kein zertifikat brauchen wir nicht
folder mosquito active
Ja perfekt ich glaube ich glaube die default settings gehen eigentlich ganz gut klar
start
Logs
Ja
Ok
scheint zu funktionieren
Und wenn ich das richtige erinnerung habe
Sollte der eigentlich jetzt sogar sagen möchtest du nicht mqtt installieren wir haben erkannt du hast einen
broker laufen
Ja genau macht er auch
Discoveries da man irgendwie ist die ganze seite nicht so ganz synchron oder was haben die da gebaut
Konfigur
Submit
Okay nice da sind wir sehr schön
Alles klar ich glaube jetzt können wir das motor integration hinzufügen
Discovery topic prefix das motor discovery perfekt wunderbar
Wie ging der scheiß denn noch mal
Moment
Muss musste man das auf den geräten selbst machen
Ich jetzt muss ich muss mal die hilfeseite habe ich habe das lange nicht mehr gemacht hier das motor integration
Once you configure the home assistant integration every new test motor device with that option
19 0
Will be discovered automatically all this motor device will be listed in their own m discovery card menu
Aber vorher muss ich wahrscheinlich mqtt settings einstellen oder ich habe das eine ganze weile nicht mehr gemacht
Genau man hat die nämlich gar nicht mit der ip hinzugefügt das habe ich jetzt das habe ich falsch im kopf gehabt
Genau man muss jetzt
man muss jetzt in die
man muss jetzt erst mal konfiguration konfigure mqtt host
dann braucht man hier
Port 1883 ist der default pod client
defas user
User brauchen wir admin wir haben ja wir haben ja nur unser standard passwort 1 wir haben nur den einen user am start
Ich glaube so ist das okay safe
Menü wenn wir jetzt hier in den
in das add-on gucken in die add-on logs
Dann sollte der sich ja eigentlich auch anmelden an unserem broker log sollte da nicht irgendwas stehen
Leute ich muss mal kurz ich muss euch mal ganz kurz aus mal ich bin mir nicht sicher ob man da jetzt nicht irgendwelche sachen
Ich schalte ich halte euch einfach dahin dann seht ihr nix
Was sind das also ich oh oh oh leute mein konsolen output sind nicht gut aus guckt mal
Mein das motor konsolen output ist irgendwie ein bisschen broken serial buffer overrun
Die die milf rasteck dose hat ein paar probleme würde ich sagen
Gut die ist ja auch im anderen netz das muss ich ah leute ich weiß woran es liegt firewall freischaltung
Ich brauche eine firewall freischaltung dass es funktioniert das mache ich jetzt mal schnell
Konfigure mqtt weil normalerweise muss man ja nicht von außen aus nach innen zugreifen
Aber in dem fall braucht man das weil das ja in einem eigenen iot netz steht
Mache ich mache ich doch mal schnell
firewall
Except source address nach source address ist mir jetzt egal source address irgendeine
Destination adress 1 2 2 2 punkt 1 2 7
port
tcp
Port tcp port
Okay jetzt speichern wir das ganze in nebel
destination 2.127
1883 ok ich habe eine firewall freischaltung drinne
Gucken wir mal ob es jetzt ob es jetzt besser aussieht ja
Mqtt das sieht doch schon besser aus
Das macht jetzt dinger oder auch nicht was für eine firewall benutzt du die auf meinem mqtt router
Geht das jetzt hat es jetzt was gemacht command anon serial buffer overrun what the fuck
Sieht nicht so aus als konnektiert er sich oder wir machen mal restart man weiß ja nie
Aber die die firewall freischaltung sieht gut aus und es ist auch 1887
Probieren wir mal aus
Configuration
1883 habe ich auch richtig ok probieren wir mal
Helmets
1883 ja
Okay da ist was
Was was ist das problem alter was ist denn hier schon wieder los
Monka w
Admin username habe ich doch gemacht
Ach so du meinst im home assistant jeder müsste der noch was anderes sagen ich bin mir relativ sicher der standard user geht schon
Probieren wir das doch mal aus mons
Kito mons wir brauchen hier mal mqtt
Moskito
Es
Saab da brauche ich ein exempel für
wie das funktioniert
sich dazu verbinden
Ja nice nice nice nice
genau minus
screenshots ok minus h 1 2 2 1 2 1 2 7 war es
Port ich hoffe dass es minus p ist
guck mal
Topic minus t einfach alles
Hm
Connection refused warum was ist da los
und ein kleines connected
Nee, das ist lokal connected ja
Ne geht doch funktioniert doch hat alles funktioniert
Warum ist der connection refused muss ich doch noch port 1883 machen oder so
not authorized
ok
Also mal user admin password 1 falls es überhaupt so geht
Jetzt
Wie geht man hier ein passwort an bei diesem fucking ding
Minus groß p minus klein u minus groß p exzellent
Pfundst ok gut
Da ist doch milfra am start leute hat alles funktioniert das was gut bei sagt er ist offensichtlich falsch
Funktioniert doch auch so
Ich mache das auch nicht zum ersten mal
Okay hat funktioniert gut
Nice wir mussten das kann man muss in den kram einfach noch mal
Neu starten und guck jetzt hat er auch nicht mal so probleme mit serial buffer overrun
Naja doch gut wie auch immer zumindest sollte er das sollte er das ganze jetzt discoveren hat er das dann eventuell schon
discovered alles
ja
Da ist es doch schon ja das ist easy hier für die weiß milfra
Milfra signal milfra ip
One device milfra
Wenn ich jetzt hier klicke leute sollte die lampe angehen
Ja, nice funktioniert und wieder aus
klick
sieht man alles
ssid und und zeug
Gut sehr schön wie wirst du später den akara fp2 integrieren das weiß ich noch nicht genau
Das weiß ich noch nicht genau ich weiß nämlich ob der zigby oder wie oder wifi ist
Wenn der wifi ist dann kann ich das heute nicht machen da muss ich ihn vorher erst mal einrichten
Okay edit dashboard card switch hier button switch
macht der standard switch eigentlich
vor nintendo switch
toggle
Das sagt halt ein bisschen
Ja lassen wir mal das standardmäßig so wie es ist
name ja lampe ist wurscht
okay
Und jetzt haben wir unser dashboard jetzt können wir das triggern lampe an lampe aus funktioniert
Wie ihr übrigens jetzt ja auch hier im in der vorschau hier seht guckt an aus
Funktioniert also das ging schon mal ganz gut und das war auch ziemlich easy
Jetzt bei stream steuern lassen twitch plays home assistant
Das war einfach muss man sagen dass es mittlerweile ziemlich gut gemacht wenn man das motor verwendet
das mal so
ansonsten passt hier gar nichts drauf
an aus
Okay, also erster versuch war schon mal erfolgreich unsere steckdose
Ist
am start in home assistant das was wir jetzt als nächstes gucken ist ich muss in meinen
Ich muss in meinen router gucken in der hoffnung
meine lampe meldet sich
meldet sich auch ordentlich an und ich bekomme bei dhcp eine ip
Erst mal kurz schauen
Ich schalte die lampe jetzt ein und guck mal vom dhcp server ob sich da irgendwas meldet
Lampe wl ed ist sie das ja nice
Das müssen wir erst mal updaten
Das muss das müssen wir erst mal updaten guck mal die lampe ist richtig richtig
altes wl ed das ist wl ed von
sieht man dass da wl ed 12 ich glaube das ist gar nicht so alt aber trotzdem ziemlich alt
Was ist das aktuelle github wl ed
Er cookie
Ach so hintendran sind wir gar nicht guck mal
Wir nehmen wir mal die letzte kommt nehmen wir mal die letzte stable version oder nehmen wir beta 1
soap oktopus
Ach komm leute leute sollen wir die serie für beta nehmen oder oder die die beta mit einem back
Wir nehmen die beta die lampe kaputt machen kann no no risk no fun
Mit dem homekit adam kannst du das ganze später per iphone steuern oder klar ja ja
Ja ich weiß aber ich steuere das schon mit dem iphone allerdings mache ich einfach die home assistant app auf
Ok wl ed
Glaube du benutzt arch by the way original arch muss man dazu sagen by the way
Irgendjemanden planen wo man sieht was anders in esp 2 nach 66 ok
Wollte sagen bin mir nämlich gar nicht mehr sicher was ich überhaupt drinnen habe für eine led für
Für microcontroller in der lampe also lasst uns mal was runterladen was haben wir denn hier sp 01 und sp 02
Was ist denn der unterschied dazwischen?
und erst bis 86
Was ist das was sind das für images sp 01 und sp 02 also ich bin mir relativ sicher dass ich das hier brauche
Übrigens ich hoffe dass upgrade funktioniert
security und updates
Wie lädt man denn hier firmenwärts überhaupt hoch ach so ok
Raus
Ja download lite binary machen wir ja download haben wir schon
update dann hoffen wir mal dass es funktioniert
Da bin jetzt mal gespannt so mehrere versions sprünge vielleicht vergisst er jetzt die wlan zugangsdaten und sowas
Ich mag es ja nicht hoffen
Das wäre echt doof hat er gerade gesagt
successfully updated
Jetzt habe ich irgendwas irgendwas eingeschaltet was ich einschalten würde
Jetzt jetzt jetzt spackt sie ab aber ich glaube das ist der effekt
viel zu hell
Ich will ich will das netzteil jetzt ja nicht über überlasten da
alle brightness und wir machen
Händler candle multi bester effekt
wow
Epileptische anfall ich weiß nicht ob ihr das seht das ist das ist voll am abkacken gerade ja jetzt ist besser
Jetzt ist jetzt ist besser
Wo das das spack mega rum ich glaube so viel ich glaube das netzteil kann nicht so viel liefern
So wunderbar jetzt haben wir hier unseren tollen candle effekt
Seht ihr das eigentlich in der vorschau gescheit
guckt dass das das flackert jetzt so ein bisschen so wie
so wie candles halt
gut und jetzt binden wir das ganze ein in home assistant
Hat das sieht man mit der kamera nicht so gut weil
Es gibt glaube ich auch eine fix und fertige integration für weder led die mittlerweile schon dabei ist ja weder led host
Damit ja mega mega
würde ich sagen
Direkt direkt am start da können wir gleich hier noch mal ein schalter hinzufügen direkt für die lampe
Button weder led
Sehr schön ja lampe anne moment
Die led lampe so so und jetzt kann man hier in home assistant
Was kostet sowas nix das habe ich selbst gemacht
Das habe ich komplett also mein zum bauen also das gehäuse muss der 3d drucken
Und die hardware da drin dass der esp kostet ich drei euro
Der ist 60 16 mal 16 led matrix tja weiß ich nicht was kostet was aktuell auf
amazon also ich habe sie bei aliexpress gekauft
habe aliexpress kostet 10 euro oder so
Da brauchst du noch ein netzteil also wahrscheinlich kostet das so 30 euro oder so
so was zu bauen
Ich habe übrigens nicht vergessen zurückzuschalten
auf den desktop
So jetzt habe ich hier noch mal die lampe hinzugefügt
Das kann man hier direkt drüber ein und ausschalten und die steckdose bleibt an
Und
Wenn man lang drückt kann man jetzt hier auch die die sachen wie intensität und so einstellen wie ihr vielleicht sieht
Erkennt man den unterschied wenn ich jetzt hier volle pulle mache
Wird es dann auch heller im stream ein bisschen ja
Und jetzt und jetzt wieder fast aus
Ja sieht man schon
Ja und man kann auch direkt drüber ein ausschalten man kann hier die temperatur
Einschalten und man kann effekte umschalten also im prinzip kann man mehr oder weniger alles was man übers webinterface macht mittlerweile auch über home assistant steuern
Das ist schon schon sehr nice da kann man dann auch so gestörtes zeug machen wie bling rainbow
was halt
übertrieben nervig ist wenn man so was neben sich stehen hat gut
Das war jetzt ja easy relativ erfolgreich
Das funktioniert gut dann werde ich das mal ein bisschen zur seite stellen und jetzt
Chat wir kümmern wir uns mal um das thema sick be oder sick be
War das hier mal ein bisschen zur seite ich lasse es mal dran dass wir da ein bisschen dran rum basteln können nachher noch aber
Ich mache es einfach mal ein bisschen weg
Dass es nicht so im weg steht
Das hier machen wir auch mal ein bisschen weg dass es nicht so im wow
Alter wie habe ich wie habe ich denn was wie habe ich das denn geschafft
Einfach mal hierhin
Dann würde ich sagen fangen wir mal mit dem sonostick an aber vorher müssen wir den guide lesen
Wie hast wie hast du das nun hinzugefügt ich bin hier auf settings gegangen habe gesagt integrations
Und habe einfach eine wl ed integration hinzugefügt und die ip meines wl ed
controllers angegeben guck
Controllers angegeben guck
Und dann erscheint das automatisch hier drin
Mit allen möglichen sachen die dazugehören und wenn du das hinzugefügt hast dann kannst du die ganzen sachen in ein dashboard
reinhauen dann kannst du dann einen ausschalten
Oder halt wenn du lang drauf drückst in dem fall die ganzen settings dran vornehmen also das ist schon deutlich besser geworden
Wie das noch am anfang mit der integration war das ist jetzt wirklich sehr nice
Real pound extremely pound den subscribe button würde ich sagen ein richtig echter
Musik ist vorbei für den sub
Gut so jetzt kümmern wir uns um die sick bie geschichte sick bie to mq tt
Home assistant
Wir müssen uns jetzt erst mal angucken weil angeblich muss man den stick flashen das wird was werden sage ich euch
Supported devices nee das brauchen wir nicht
Geils installation konfiguration adapter
Adapters ja
Recommended sonoff
Usb hier usb connected easiest
Note before buying that is slightly confusing now sells both the dongle minus p and the dongle minus e
sections about dongle minus p for
Okay, ich habe den minus p also alles gut alles gut was router firmware
Moment jetzt jetzt bin jetzt bin ich verwirrt
Geht es jetzt einfach out of the box oder ich muss den flashen
Und was ist der unterschied zwischen einem koordinator und einer firmen und einer route und einem router
What
Koordinator gleich steuereinheit router leitet weiter ja so schlau wäre ich auch gewesen aber ich habe genau ein stick ist es jetzt
ein router oder ein koordinator
Das ist kann ja auch ein router sein es bezieht sich auf das gleiche
Muss man das machen oder geht das einfach so
Konbi guck mal was ich guck mal was die konbi dinger sagen
Achso konbi unterstützt das unterstützt den konbi direkt
Und ansonsten muss ich erst mal flashen wie es aussieht flashing instructions
Doc
Gott
Gegen wörtdokument aber pdf version
Nehmen die anleitung ja ich habe die noch habt die schon offen hier
Irgendwo habe ich die offen
Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich das überhaupt flashen muss
das überhaupt flashen
Wisst ihr was wisst ihr was wir jetzt mal einfach ausprobieren
Ich stöpsel das ding jetzt mal
An meinen home assistant dran ich muss es flashen und wir gucken mal was der home assistant sagt
Du musst es nicht flashen
tja
Home assistant addon
okay
Erst mal gucken was passiert wenn ich überhaupt mein sick be stick dran stecke
Probieren wir das mal aus
Gehen wir mal ein home assistant rein
vorher installieren wir aber noch ein anderes addon wir installieren vorher noch ein
Ssh addon
Advanced terminal install dass wir da ordentlich per ssh drauf kommen
Jetzt brauche ich glaube ich mein ssh key gleich hat punkt ssh
Vermutlich der hier
Wupplorts at gmx.de klingt erst mal gut
Meine streaming e-mail adresse das passt
Fügen wir gleich mal hinzu
Da ist ein koordinator vor okay wir sick be
koordinator vs router
Okay, genau erklärt uns das mal
Ja, die erklären jetzt doch router
Router
Okay
Okay, ach so das heißt ich könnte den auch als router flashen und dann quasi um mein mesh
Netzwerk zu erweitern irgendwo dran stöpseln
Okay, das ist gut zu wissen also heißt ich brauche auf jeden fall einen koordinator
Das ist quasi das was ein sick be steckdose von haus aus macht
Routen aber ich könnte das auch mit diesem usb stick machen verstehe verstehe
konfiguration packages ne passwort nein
Keys wo kann ich meine keys hinterlegen
authorized keys
Da wo bloß am start
Wo bloß in der hut hass io passwort muss man key authentifizierung einschalten
Gucken wir mal schauen wir mal ob das jetzt funktioniert
Ssa hass io
Verifikiert hier ssa key gen minus er
Yes permission denied
What wie jetzt?
Public
was
Kein zeilen robot seine zu seine zeile das formatieren macht das ding hier so
Was jetzt für ein problem log
Habe ich irgendwie misst kopiert
Ich meine
Max erdpoggers geht auch klar ja kann man auch nehmen
Okay auf let's go
okay
Max max erdpoggers anscheinend alles in ordnung
Gut jetzt können wir nämlich auch per ssh drauf
Und es ein bisschen angucken was da so abgeht aktuell
Gut schauen wir doch mal
Also wir brauchen einen koordinator das ist sinnvoll wir schauen jetzt mal ob vielleicht weil ich habe gelesen
Das home assistant mittlerweile ziemlich high iq ist ist das nicht port 2222 ist es nicht
Warum auch ich meine haus hat ja kein ssh laufen da kann ruhig auf port 22
Der home assistant ist nämlich ziemlich big brain und kann mittlerweile sogar usb sticks updaten und sowas ich weiß aber nicht ob es den
Zigbee stick updaten kann das probieren wir jetzt einfach mal aus
Wo das zigbee
Er hat ihn schon mal erkannt den son of zigbee dongle
New devices discovered check it out sick be ich das will ich nicht das ist
Random weirdo dankeschön high iq move
Richtig high iq hoch iq sozusagen
Danke für den sub
Ja das wollen wir hier nicht machen ignore wir wollen keine zigbee automatisierung absetzen
Also man sollte hier also es ist so es gibt mehrere möglichkeiten wie man zigbee in home assistant integrieren kann
Home assistant bringt eine zigbee integration mit aber in der vergangenheit war es zumindest so ich weiß nicht wie das wie das noch ist aber
Ich vermute mal es ähnlich war zigbee to mqtt von der kompatibilität her einfach der king
Versus das normale home assistant
Also ich glaube das war es für heute
Das war es für heute
die
Mindemann gewoon gemacht
Ja jetzt bin ich jetzt endlich an der koalition
Kommen wir zum
Koncert
gerade
für
Das konzert
Wann will ich noch machen
Aber unbekannt
meines wir dürfen auch sich nicht beschäftigen mit meinem
Konzert
Stick Updaten
Ihr könnt es euch aussuchen
Schreibt es mir einfach in den Chat, was wir zuerst ausprobieren sollen
Ihr Updates
Vielleicht schlägt ihr mir das vor für den Stick
Beides dann
Gucken wir ob das Home Assistant kann
Nun gut
Ja geht anscheinend nicht für den Stick
Dann updaten wir das Ganze
Jetzt erstmal
Okay wir brauchen diese Anleitung
Wie geht das?
Wie updatet man den Stick?
Wir haben diese Anleitung zur Auswahl
Hier
How to
Einen Sonoff Zigbee Dongle
Ist ja im Prinzip egal
Voraussetzungen
Installation auf dem
Blablabla
Was muss ich machen?
Ist das Windows Only?
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Ich update nicht
Wenn es Windows Only ist
Ich lade mir doch keine Windows Software runter
Um meinen Stick zu updaten
Boah
Da könnte ich ja schon wieder kotzen
Wenn ich das sehe
What the
Alter
Das ist ja eine Wissenschaft für sich
Den Stick zu updaten
Download
ZNP Firmware
Ich bin mega
Verwirrt
Home Assistant
Muss man was runterladen?
Kann man von Home Assistant was runterladen?
Hä?
Das ist doch Mist was da drin steht
CC265
Ach das verweist
Einfach nur auf
Auf diesen Kram
Ja das ist es hier
Das müsste das Richtige sein
Gucken wir mal
Wie das geht
So also was schreiben die denn
Hier
Also wir brauchen die Coordinator
Firmware
Coordinator
Flashing Instructions
Ok das haben wir offen
Das ist einfach mal der falsche Link
Das ist ja schon ganz geil für die Anleitung
Ach Moment
Hä Moment
Die verweisen untereinander
Auf die
Gleichen Seiten
Ok
Weird Champ
Firmware Flashing
USB
Enter the serial port bootloader
There are two ways
For dongle to enter bootloader
Manual mode
Keep pressing the boot button
Restart the device and release the boot button
After dongle enters the serial port bootloader
Automatically enters the serial
Port bootloader
Through a python script
Moment steht da was?
Wait a minute was zum
Nächste Anleitung
Fehlen da vielleicht ein paar Bilder
Wie
Ok das ist wieder
Ein Wettbewerb
Wie konfus möchten sie es machen
Einen
Stick zu flashen
Alter China
Chinesen Zeug man
After executing the file
Enter 5555
In the serial port assistant tool
And then return 00
CC
Alles klar
Perfekt geht gut los
Und und dann
Ach du Scheiße
Und dann irgendwelche China
Äh
Jetzt
Jetzt mal ganz klar da gibt es doch irgendwelche
Fertigen Tools für
Ok das ist das ist die Manual Variante
Oder
Das ist way to dank
Using flash programmer
To
Ich würde ja ganz gerne einfach mal die Firmware auslesen
Das würde mir ja schon reichen
What the fuck
Alter das kann doch nicht sein
Da gibt es doch
Irgendwelche fertigen Sachen
Sonoff
ZigB
P
Flash GitHub
Gib mir ein GitHub wo du es unter Linux einfach machen kannst
Ja das
Würde mich interessieren wie man das einfach macht
Ja
Das da ok
Chat Gedenk mit
Äh
Da bin ich mir aber nicht
Ok damit kann man das unter Linux machen
Ok
Leute Leute ich habe eine Idee
Ich habe eine Idee wie wir das machen
Und zwar
Hier in der Anleitung steht ja was man braucht
So
Software zum Flashen runterladen
Man soll hier hingehen
Wir starten das jetzt einfach unter Wine
Wir machen ein Snapshot
Von meiner 4M vor
Man weiß ja nie was man sich da so installiert
Ok was muss man runterladen
Im Abschnitt
Flash Programmer 2
Ok den Flash Programmer 2
Muss man runterladen
Geht mit Wine Device Zugriff
Weiß ich nicht probieren wir jetzt gleich mal aus
Flash Programmer 2
Download Option
Warum sieht das so kacke aus
Please Dark Reader
Ah Gott die Webseite
Installer
Flash Programmer
Das ist jetzt nicht
Euer Ernst oder
No God
Please No
Ein Text des Instruments Account
No
Ich denke mir mal kurz ein temporäres Passwort aus
Ok
Beste
Beste Passwort ever
Kommt man nie drauf
Ähm
Frankfurt
Ich bin CEO
Aerospace
In Defense
No God
Please No
Hat der irgendwie gesagt diese E-Mail ist nicht erlaubt
Oder
Ja ich dachte mir das man E-Mail bestätigen muss
Aber
Da kam ja nichts zum bestätigen
Fucking Shit Alter
Warum müssen die dir immer nerven
Warum müssen die dir immer auf den Sack gehen mit Accountzwang
Ich ess mal kurz ein Stück
So warum müssen die dich immer abfacken
Mit Accountzwang das ist so ätzend
Ok
Also dann testen wir doch mal das Linux Tool
Sonoff
Zigbee
Flash Linux
Guck mal was ist denn das
Guck mal wir kriegen sogar
Perfekt
Hallo und herzlich willkommen
Hier zu einem weiteren Video
Der erklärt uns das jetzt
Wie auch immer der genau heißt
Zu dem hab ich ja schon mal ein anderes Video gemacht
Und den ausführlich vorgestellt
Und der Stick ist auch bis heute meine Empfehlung
Wenn du dich mit dem Thema Zigbee beschäftigen möchtest
Bevor wir mit dem Update Prozess starten
Möchte ich dir nochmal ganz kurz
Die SEO Broker Installation 2021
Erstmal ein bisschen Sellout
Immer gut
Die Firmware dafür finden wir ja in diesem
Report
ZStack Firmware
Ach Moment im Internet gibt es das
Es gibt es zum Downloaden
Aber Moment ich brauche den
HProgrammer 2
Video gezeigt
Und hier brauchen wir einen Coordinator
ZStack 3x0 bin
Da bin ich schon drin
Ja okay
Das haben wir schon runtergeladen
Das machen wir jetzt als nächstes
Das heißt ich werde jetzt das
Ganze erstmal vorbereiten
Für das Update
Ja okay
Ja
Okay
Ja okay
So alles klar
Okay
Also das Ding
Wieso sind solche Hardware Dinger so
Scheiße zu flashen
Ganz ehrlich da nehmen sich die China
Chinesen und die anderen Hersteller nicht viel
Das
Das ist immer so scheiße
Warum ist es so scheiße
Abhängigkeiten und zwar mit PIP
Haben wir ja schon installiert
Da habe ich
Hier schon Satisfied
Also die hatten wir ja gerade manuell installiert
Wunderbar und jetzt brauchen wir die
Firmware Datei
Da hatten wir ja schon rausbekommen
Was hat er installiert
Ähm
Ja okay
Da hatten wir ja schon rausbekommen
Dass ich aus dem ZStack
Ja
Habe ich schon runtergeladen
Okay hier
Es ist toll dass das
Die Leiste darüber
Python bla bla bla
Serial
Magic Command okay
Muss das jetzt geflasht werden
Naja zumindest dass ich die aktuelle Firmware habe
Und aktuelle Firmware mal Initial ist so nicht verkehrt
Also wahrscheinlich geht es auch so
Texas Instruments
Lässt mich nicht downloaden
Hier scheiß drauf
Kann ich das hier drüber machen
Das wäre extremly Pog
Wenn das hier drüber funktionieren würde
Über das SSH
Addon ansonsten
Ich meine ich kann es auch an die VM
Aber wir probieren das mal
SSH
Shit ist drauf
Pip install
Ist das jetzt was
Äh
Pip install Punkt
Du du du du du
Du du du du
Du du du
Zumindest das Ding zu installieren
Geht auch schon mal
Ja verständlich
Ah hier guck mal
Okay
Hat funktioniert
CC
BSL Python
After
Kack
Ja gut da muss ich jetzt
Den richtigen Kram angeben
Für den Zigbee Stick
Fuck
Also
Minus P
Def
Serial
By ID
Sonoff
Und dann hat er was noch
Minus E Minus V Minus W
Was auch immer
CC
Minus Minus
Minus Minus Boot
Loader
Minus Sonoff
Minus USB
Und dann
Achso
Da muss ich die Firmware erst runterladen
Von wo hab ich die
Firmware runtergeladen
Copy Download Link
Okay unzip
Hex
Okay
Und jetzt muss ich da hinten angeben
Die Firmware
Schau mal ob das funktioniert
Easy
Easy as fuck
Einfach
Einfach mal Anleitung
Ich glaub das wars
Drücken auf den USB Stick
Ich bin drin
Ich hoffe ihr seid auch drin
Verified
Wunderbar
Ja und da jetzt
Okay
Nice easy
Richtig easy
Wir können jetzt ja weiter machen
So also
Gehen wir mal jetzt hier hin
Integrations
Zigbee
Configure
Also wir probieren beides
Also wir schauen mal womit das besser funktioniert
Das Thermostat
Do you want to setup Sonoff
Zigbee USB Dongle Plus
Sonoff Zigbee 3.0 USB Dongle Plus
Dongle Plus
Wird gesetupt
Ah doch
Weil ich den Stick quasi
Einmal ausgesteckt habe durch den Reboot
Virtuell
Easy
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
Leuchte das irgendwie
Macht das irgendwas
Chat
Ihr habt das doch schonmal gemacht mit dem eingebauten Home Assistant
Zigbee
Wie lange dauert das jetzt
Error
Excellent
Hat das jetzt doch funktioniert
Okay
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen es geht jetzt doch
Finish
Erfolgreich wehgeschlagen
Yep
Ähm
Ich hab die Zigbee Home Assistant
Integration noch nie benutzt
Sollte hier ein bisschen mehr stehen oder ist das alles okay so
Wir ändern mal
Wir ändern mal ein Device
Wir ändern mal hier
Zum testen
Wir ändern mal ein Device
Wo ich mir sehr sicher bin dass es funktionieren muss
Nämlich
Einfach das Teil hier guck mal
Das ist so ein
Acara
Temperatursensor
Das
Teil ist es genau
Ähm
Da bräuchte ich jetzt mal die Anleitung wie man den
Paired
Wahrscheinlich einfach nur
Drücken unten
Searching for Zigbee Device
Make sure you have devices in pairing mode
Ja
Aha easy
Lumi Lumi
Bei Lumi
Äh
Hat das jetzt geändert
Oder muss ich noch was machen
Da ist es doch
Lumi Lumi
Ach hier steht ein bisschen mehr
Aha
Lumi Lumi ist am Start
Lumi Lumi Wetter
Temperature 26,4 Grad
Pressure
Humidity
Battery 84%
Moment macht das was
Leuchte das wenn ich da drauf drücke
Also das macht
Also der Button macht nichts
Aber okay
Lumi Lumi
Gut der Stick an sich funktioniert
Dann kommen wir mal zum spannenden Part
Ach so meinst du das mit Pusten
Das funktioniert schon
Das sieht man ja auch an der Temperatur
Also können wir ausprobieren ob sich die Luftfeuchtigkeit ändert
Wenn ich reinpuste
Wahrscheinlich hier vorne
Ja eindeutig
Katschibas
Okay
Funktioniert mit Pusten
Ja zu der eigentlichen
Geschichte die ich ausprobieren wollte
Lumi Lumi am Start
Das Ding
Oh
Angeblich geht das nur mit einer
Bosch Bridge
Schauen wir mal ob das magic Art und Weise
Einfach funktioniert im
Home Assistant direkt
Out of the Box
Ich glaub es ja nicht
Aber wisst ihr was
Probieren wir mal
Testen wir mal
Oh fuck jetzt hab ich es aufgerissen
Probieren wir das doch mal aus
Bosch
Okay gut verpackt
Das ist schonmal
I am smart
Die wollen uns quasi sagen sie sind 5Head
Aber das bezweifle ich
5Head ist nur der Twitch Chat hier
Und Primers
Ausschließlich Prime Subscribers
Normale Subscriber auch
Die sind sogar noch schlauer
Weil die haben erkannt worauf es ankommt
Okay Installation
Guide
Was haben wir hier wahrscheinlich Batterien und sowas
Batterien
Ja
Und und und
Nochmal
Batterien
Ach ne das ist so
Das ist nur zum installieren von dem Ding
Für das
Hier zum installieren
Am
Heiz
Heizkörper
Hier sind die Batterien drin
Okay
Bosch Radiator Quick Instructions
Okay Quick Instructions
Wie pairt man das ganze
Wir lesen prinzipiell
Keine Handbücher
Die Kamera sieht weird aus
Ja weil es 60 FPS sind
Wenn ich es auf 30 stelle
Sieht das nicht so flüssig aus
Dafür normaler
Wie macht man hier die Batterien rein
Wahrscheinlich so
Also wir gucken einfach mal
Was sie dazu schreiben
Bosch
Thermostat 2
Ja
Da ist es doch
Thermostat 2
Pairing
To pair this device you have to install the device
Installation code
The installation code can be obtained by scanning the QR code
On the side of the battery cover
With your smartphone
Then get the device into pairing mode
In ZigBee M2TT settings
Navigate to
Settings tools and then click on add install
Oh das kann bestimmt
Das eingebaute Home Assistant Ding nicht
Paste the code to get from the
Moment was
Paste the code to get from the QR code
Achso Chat jetzt seh ich ja gar nichts
Ach da was
Das hat ein QR Code
Oh tatsächlich
Ah tatsächlich ein QR Code guck mal
QR Code
Erkennt man zwar kaum aber da ist ein QR Code drin
Honge
Leaked
Leute jetzt könnt ihr meinen Thermostat fernsteuern
Chat manchmal
Hab ich das Gefühl ihr denkt ich bin total dämlich
Das mag ja in manchen Sachen
Auch so sein
Aber dass ich weiß dass ich nicht
ZigBee M2TT verwende also ich mein das
Könnt man glaub ich mittlerweile mitgekriegt haben
Ja dann ist die Frage
Kann man überhaupt
Mit dem
Home Assistant Ding adden mit
Code geht das überhaupt
ZHA
Code
Aha ja anscheinend anscheinend
To join a new device
Using an install code
Use the following data attributes
Oh das ist noch ein bisschen mehr
Installation angesagt
Äh
Wie funktioniert das jetzt
Das ist mir zu high IQ das versteh ich nicht
Okay also ich mein ich komme bis hier hin
Service
ZHA
Okay
Ich glaube das brauch ich gar nicht
Must be used with
Was ist
Moment das ist meine MAC Adresse von dem
Von dem
Wo soll ich denn meine MAC Adresse wissen
Steht das da drinnen
Tatsächlich steht das da drinnen
Und da steht sogar der Code daneben
Das steht da
Leute das stimmt überhaupt nicht was da steht
Da steht drinnen ich soll
Paste the code you got from
QR Code and confirm by clicking okay
Da steht sogar ein install
Code daneben
Dann probieren wir das doch einfach mal
Ich mein mehr als kaputt gehen kanns nicht
Okay
Also
Source IEE
In welchem Muster muss man das
Schreiben
Also draufstehen tuts so
18FC
Boah
Boomer Augen alter
18FC
Oh fuck
Wie viele Nullen sind das jetzt
Okay soviel Nullen
C
2F
Ich muss mal die Nullen zählen
Das ist ziemlich klein
Also nur das ihr das mal seht
Das ist nicht für Boomer Augen
Gemacht hier guckt
Also wie viele Nullen
Ich bin zu dumm das zu sehen
Boomer Augen
Sind nur 5 Nullen
Das können wir auch einfach überprüfen
So eine MAC Adresse
Für ein ZigBee Gerät ist wie lang
Das ist wahrscheinlich so richtig
Ich glaub sind nur 5 Nullen
Ja sind nur 5 Nullen
Ja
Okay und jetzt den Install Code
Install Code trage ich mal ein
Und jetzt drücke ich auf Add
Und jetzt probieren wir es
Ich mach jetzt gleich die Batterien rein
Äh
Chatgear ich bin zu blöd das zu benutzen
Guck mal
Invalid
Also der Install Code steht da so drauf
Oder muss ich
Alle 3 Codes
Reinschreiben
Da steht nämlich 3 Codes drauf
Ich hab leider keinen Barcode Scanner
Grad am Start
Das ist bisschen doof
Mein Barcode Scanner ist da in dem Handy
Was ich grad als Kamera benutze
Mal gucken ob ich das Screenshotten kann
Oder im Internet irgendwie
Was?
Alter ich will einfach nur ein fucking Screenshot machen
Paint
Alter ich fasse das Ding hat jetzt
Kein Screenshot gemacht
Ich kann ja nicht einfach ein Screenshot machen
Ja super jetzt kann ich die Taste nicht dafür drücken
Warte mal ich hab ne Idee
Pass mal auf
Pfeiffertime
Äh das ist zu
Exposure
Äh
Erkennt man leider nicht richtig
Alter was ein Scheiß wieder
Ich fasse es nicht
Kann ich mal einen popeligen Screenshot machen
Was ist denn das für ein Müll
Warum kann ich nicht einfach
Snipping Tool
So ein Schrott alter
Warum kann ich nicht ein Full Size Screenshot machen
Ich will einfach
Ein Full Size Screenshot machen
Mit Drucken
Warum ist das default mäßig nicht mehr aktiviert
Was ist das für ne Kacke
Warum gibt es so Dinger
Full Screen Mode
Ja auch okay
Das ist richtig dumm
Okay
Ist das jetzt scharf
Ich hoffe mal das es scharf genug ist
Dass man QR Code
Ja perfekt Snipping Tool
Ups
Und wo hat das Snipping Tool den Chat jetzt gespeichert
Hier Screenshots
Das ist im Leben
Meint ihr es gibt irgendein QR Tool
Was das checkt
Im Leben nicht
Kein QR Tool kann das gescheit erkennen
Ich tipp das jetzt einfach weiter
Wie sieht denn so ein
ZigBee Install Code aus
Gibt es einfach irgendein Exempel für
So
Okay so
Wie sieht das aus
Ohne Bindestriche
Also
Komplette Zumutung
Hat das jetzt funktioniert
Ich hoffe mal
Ich mach jetzt mal Batterien rein
Schauen wir mal
Gucken wir ob sich das jetzt
Pairt
Was steht hier
Okay
Hat das jetzt
Hat das jetzt gejoined
Oder nicht
Gucken wir mal
Doch 3 Devices
Es ist doch
Das hat einfach instant
Funktioniert
Kecke
Was ist das
Geht einfach
Einfach so
Ja Moment
Aber
Wie stelle ich da jetzt was ein
Schauen wir mal
Add
Einen eigenen Button
Thermostat
Ja cool
Check
Aus
28,2
Es ist ja noch nicht installiert
Deswegen wird es noch nicht funktionieren
Es ist halt nicht an der Heizung dran
Das wird es wahrscheinlich
Deswegen wird es nichts machen
Dann
Off
Zeigt an das es installiert werden muss
Ich würde jetzt
Ich würde jetzt mal vermuten
Es geht
Würde jetzt einfach funktionieren
Muss aber nicht
Ja du musst es anschließen
Du musst es höchstwahrscheinlich anschließen
Das es was macht
Aber Leute ich habe ehrlich gesagt keinen Bock
An meiner Heizung jetzt rumzuschrauben
Ja
Kommt scheiß drauf Leute
Ich schraube es jetzt an meine Heizung dran
Ich will jetzt wissen ob das funktioniert
Will ich die Qualität
Ganz ehrlich
Macht einen guten Eindruck
Ich schraube mal das alte
Ich muss mal eine kurze Zange holen
Chat
Wer hat noch die hier
Von euch
Das somit eines der verbreitetsten Zangen
In dieser Welt
Die Knibbecks Rohr
Rohr
Dings
Wie nennt man sowas Rohrzange
Die ist massive
Ich habe total viele Leute gesehen die das Teil haben
Wahrscheinlich von euch auch ein paar
Beste
Ich mach das mal kurz ab
Dann mach ich das neue dran
Und dann gucken wir mal
Das dumme ist nur das ich jetzt so eine Kiste davor stehen hab
Und kaum dran komme
Aber ok man
Ich glaube ich hab es ab
Fritz
Geh ab Fritz
Fritzke
Geh ab
Hier
AVM Champ am Start
Ok
Macht das denn sowas
What
Macht das denn sowas oder nicht
Vielleicht muss ich das ein bisschen festschrauben
Alter ich hab keinen Platz hier neben
Aha
Jetzt zeigt es
27,8 an
Jetzt kann ich ein bisschen runterdrehen
Auf 12
Macht das jetzt was
Jetzt ist es locked
Ok das ist High IQ Thermostat
Also angeblich 27,8
Ich hör aber
Ich hör den Motor halt sich nicht bewegen
Was willst du dein Toaster auch
Was
So ganz genau check ich die
Jetzt
Jetzt hat es rot geleuchtet und hat neue Sachen bekommen
Ok
Also Leute entweder hat es einen mega leisen Motor
Oder es funktioniert nicht
So einfach ausschalten
Geht anscheinend auch nicht
Oder doch
Nö
Was passiert dann
Nichts
Also ich bin mir nicht sicher ob es funktioniert
Ehrlich gesagt
Man kann zwar hier rumstellen
Ich mach mal weiter hoch
Also entweder ist der Motor ultra leise
Oder es macht grad nichts
Richtig dran ist es würde ich sagen
So ich stell es jetzt mal auf 21
Ob es das checkt
27,2
Ok es zeigt die aktuelle Temperatur an
Aber wie kann ich ihm sagen
Jetzt hab ich es auf 22 gestellt
Oder auf 21
Jetzt hab ich es auf
22,5 gestellt
Das kriegt er hier auch gar nicht
Doch doch doch guck mal
Prinzipiell die Kommunikation scheint zu funktionieren
Bin mir nicht sicher
Wie die Calibration ist
Wir müssen mal ins Manual gucken
Thermostat 2 PDF
Aber steht bestimmt auch drin
Wie das funktioniert
Wie man es benutzen soll
Was 6,7
Raumregelung manuell
Ja da steht es grad drauf
Ähh
Was will das von mir
Mit einem Adapter
Moment
Ich brauch doch gar keinen Adapter
Oder brauch ich einen Adapter
Dafür
Ich konnte das einfach so dran schrauben
Mein Fritzding
Braucht auch keinen Adapter
Nee ich brauch da keinen Adapter
Einfach so
Ok und
Also ich kenn das von den Fritzthermostaten
Da muss ich auch initial
Müssen die einmal so komplett
Rein und raus fahren
Wie macht man denn den Anleeren
Modus
Anleeren
Nee Moment
Mit Anleeren meinen die
Verbinden mit dem
Mit dem Controller
Das muss man anscheinend
Nicht kalibrieren
Wenn ich richtig verstehe passiert das
Moment vielleicht soll ich das mal einfach neu starten
Das Teil
Man weiß ja nie
Ich starte es einfach mal neu
Ah
Jetzt
Jetzt fährt das hin und her
Ok
Alles klar
Jetzt ist es hin und her gefahren
Schauen wir mal kurz was das hier anzeigt
Ja gut nichts wirklich
Jetzt
Klingt da irgendwie merkwürdig
Hab ich mal einen Knopf gedrückt und jetzt
Jetzt brummts wieder komisch
Ok
Kalibriert sich das jetzt
Ja
Jetzt funktioniert es
Ok jetzt funktioniert es
Das muss man einmal neu starten
30 Grad
Ja
Ja ok alles gut
Bock
Jetzt funktioniert es
So jetzt muss ich nur noch die Frage wie setzt man das
Jetzt in den Sommermodus
Also hier rüber schalten kann man ja anscheinend
Nicht dass man Heating off macht
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen doof
Weil ich will ja nicht im Sommer
Das soll im Sommer ja gar nicht
An sein das soll im Sommer einfach ausgehen
Da schauen wir mal ob wir
Vielleicht hier irgendwie über Services was setzen
Können Thermostat
Oder irgendwie
Ähm
Jetzt unschlüssig wie das
Heat
Hier Climate
Climate ich glaub das zählt
Ich glaub das zählt als
Set Preset Mode
Choose Entity
Ach wie mach ich denn das bei mir nochmal
Mit dem Fritz
Wir machen mal eine Automation
Und gucken ob wir das auswählen
Create new Automation
Conditions Action
Device
Change Havoc Mode
To Off oder Heat
Ja das hat ja nicht funktioniert
Das hat ja nicht funktioniert
Wenn ich sag
Change to Off
Und sag jetzt Run
Dann macht es einfach nichts
Ich muss mal kurz in meinen anderen Home Assistant reingucken
Wie ich das für meine
Fritz Thermostate eingerichtet hab
Fritz Thermostate alle an
Alle aus für Sommer
Zum Beispiel ja
LK Modus ändern
Ja doch genau so
Genau so mach ich das da auch
Ja das ist schon mal
Das ist schon mal ziemlich Sack
Dass man hier keinen Sommer Modus einschalten kann
Ich mein vielleicht muss ich es einfach auf
5 Grad stellen
Dann geht es automatisch in den Sommer Modus
Ich bezweifle es aber
Ja
Ja aber es steht auf 5 Grad
Na geil
Das ist natürlich blöd
Wenn das nicht unterstützt wird
Dass man das Ding ausschalten kann
Das ist schon ein extremer Sack
Kann man auf die Buttons klicken
Ja aber es passiert nichts
Also die Buttons sind
Maximal useless
Gibt es vielleicht noch andere Möglichkeiten
Was man hier sagen kann
Set Preset Mode
Ja da gibt es ja nichts
Ah doch hier
Set Temperature
Heat Off
Vielleicht hier
Aber wahrscheinlich auch nicht
Das ist wahrscheinlich
Schlicht und ergreifend noch nicht implementiert
In dieser ZigBee Geschichte
Mal mit ZigBee
Testen
Schauen wir mal
Hier
Exposes
Local Temperature
Occupied
Heating
Es sieht nicht so aus
Als kann das das Ding überhaupt
Hat das
Das muss doch irgendeinen Standby Modus
Erzählt mir doch nichts Leute
Wie
Wie macht man das Ding
In Standby Modus
Raumregelung ist inaktiv
Genau das will ich haben
Und wie schalte ich das ein
Also die Bedienungsanleitung
Ist natürlich auch enorm
Extremly Pog
Okay
Probieren wir mal aus
Ich bastle jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen dran rum
Und wir schauen
Ob sich das hier was ändert
Also gehen wir mal hin
Und sagen
Set
Jetzt habe ich einfach nur den Timer gesetzt
Das will ich ja nicht
Jetzt ist es lockt wenn ich es lang drücke
Habe ich die Kindersicherung an
Das will ich ja aber nicht
Okay
Wie könnte ich das auf Heizpause
Stellen
Hm
Ich bin in Home Assistant drin
Also ich meine ich bin ja
Sogar zu blöd das einzustellen
In
In dem
Menü
Raumregelung pausiert
Ja aber wie stelle ich es ein
Geht das nur über die offizielle App zum Einstellen
Und by the way die Batterie Anzeige
Oben links habe ich auch gar nicht
Die steht bei mir einfach nicht da
Kann man das Firmware updaten
Vielleicht ist meine Firmware zu alt
Devices
Firmware
Wie macht man hier drüber
Reconfigure
Äh okay
Kann das sowas wie Firmware Update machen
Over the air
Updates
Nee nee nee das muss man ausschalten im Sommer
Das Problem ist auch das es viel zu viel Energie zieht wenn es nicht ausgeschaltet ist
Äh
To automatically download and perform OTA
Over the air firmware updates of ZigBee devices
If the
OTA firmware update is set to disabled in the configuration
By default
Okay in welcher
Konfiguration
In der normalen ZigBee
Configuration
Firmware? Nee
Äh
Ja wo denn
Kann das sein
Ach das muss man
Okay
You can choose if the Ikea
Provider should be set to enable
Also okay der kann das nicht
Der kann das nur für diese
Für diese vier Dinger
Nee
Hä ich check's nicht
Das ist mega pfeilfert
OTA directory
Nichtsdestotrotz man muss das doch auch ausstellen können
Das ist eine bescheuerte Bedienungsanleitung
Ich mein das sind Sicherheitshinweise
Und dann gibt es hier eine
Eine Anzeige
Für und nichts ist erklärt
Wie es funktioniert
Was ist das für ein Schwachsinn
Ich mein man muss doch
Einen ausschalten können direkt am
Drücken auf null
Bestätigung diverser Bedienvorgänge
Wer hat die alter
Wer hat diese Anleitung geschrieben
Und das war's mehr steht nicht drinne
Das ist ja mal mega hängen geblieben
Alter also
Ich kann set machen
Da kann ich aber nur die
Uhrzeit umstellen
Was da schonmal nichts bringt
Okay Leute
Ich hab keine Ahnung wie man das gescheit bedient
Das Teil
Schonmal sehr nice
Set
Keine Ahnung
Mega Kram Alter
Wie bescheuert kann man eine Bedienung
Machen
Ich kann da hin und her drücken
Aber es passiert nichts
Ich kann nur die Zeiten umstellen
Hat man doch grad schon
Kurzanleitung gibt es da auch
Aha guck mal hier
Wait a minute
Das ist nicht
Aber eins muss ich sagen
Verarbeitungs und so mäßig
Eindruck
Heizstatus an der Farbe erkennen
Ja super
Wenn ich wüsste wie ich den Heizstatus umschalte
An dem Gerät
Das wäre schon enorm
Gibt es da vielleicht ein Handbuch
Anleitung
Oh
Wenn das jetzt wieder
Ah das ist wieder diese Kack Anleitung
In der nichts drin steht
Das haben wir doch grad ausprobiert
Okay jetzt geht's
Okay
Moment
Ich will die Pause nicht ausschalten
Ich will die Pause einschalten
Ich will die Heizpause
Einschalten
Aber da hab ich schon wieder keinen Bock drauf
Da hab ich schon wieder
Keine
Wahrscheinlich geht das nicht
Wahrscheinlich geht das nur über die App
Haben wir das Ding Firmware updaten
Nee Firmware updaten gibt es dafür auch nicht
Was hat Firmware dafür
Vielleicht mehrmals auf null drücken
Das hab ich doch ausprobiert
Das geht nicht
Dann schaltest du nur hin und her
Zwischen der
Einer Anzeige und der anderen
Da passiert nichts
Ich krieg noch nicht mal einen Batteriestand darauf angezeigt
Was mich äußerst verwirrt
Custom Heizchamp
Entwicklung
Die Ausweitung scheint ganz gut zu sein
Bedienbarkeit komplett für den Arsch
Geht's um das Fritzgerät
Nein das Fritzgerät ist gut
Das Fritzgerät hab ich die ganze Zeit dran
Das funktioniert wunderbar
Nein ich hab so ein billiges Boschgerät
Gekauft beim Prime Day
Versucht es jetzt über ZigBee zu benutzen
Was ja prinzipiell auch funktioniert
Hier guck aber
Man kann es zum Beispiel
Nicht ausschalten
Was echt extrem bescheuert ist
Schauen wir doch mal
Was das hier ausspuckt
Devices
Integration Entries
Was wir hier machen können
Manage ZigBee Devices
Alarm Mask App Version
Date
Location
Read Attribute
None
Manufacturer ID
Bosch
Power Source
Nö
Commands
Reset Factory Default
Mehr Commands gibt's nix
Moment das hat noch mehr
Diagnostics
Das ist doch jetzt wieder was anderes oder
OTA
Ok das musst du ja mal richtig
krass studiert haben
Thermostat Endpoint
Weeklys
Get Relay Status
Get Weeklys
Ich will das Ding einfach
In
In den ausgeschaltenen
Modus versetzen
Das scheint nicht gedacht zu sein
Keine Ahnung was das wieder für ein Kack ist
Ja das ist schon
Ziemlich enttäuschend
Bosch
Bosch Thermostat
Wir hatten das doch hier offen
Für
Pairing
Units
Climate
Exposes Climate
Supports the following features
Local Temperature
Running States
System Mode
To
Control Publish
Off
Heat or Auto
Ja genau das ist das Problem
Das geht bei mir nicht
Activate Boost Heating
Ich glaube wir probieren das doch nochmal mit
ZigBee to MQTT
Gebt mal die Firmware Version bei Google ein
Ich hab noch nicht mal ein Download gefunden
Für die neue Firmware Version
Bosch
Find man einfach gar nichts
Entities not shown
Ich meine so wirklich viele Knöpfe hat das Ding ja auch nicht
Ich glaube wir müssen das noch mit
ZigBee to MQTT ausprobieren
Aber Leute wir machen
Für heute Schluss ich kann mich nicht mehr konzentrieren
Und außerdem ich muss mal übelst dringend
Aufs Klo
Wir machen genau an der Stelle
Weiter weil wir haben noch ein paar Dinge
Wir müssen irgendwie das Thermostat zum Laufen kriegen
Ähm und die anderen
ZigBee Dinger noch einbinden
Und Sachen die wir noch
Vergessen haben machen schauen wir mal
Ich geh jetzt erstmal aufs Klo Leute
Wir sehen uns bis dann machts gut
See you